we break down OverWatch 2's problematic
launch the next next Call of Duty
potentially leaks as does the imminent
release of yet another Need for Speed
game all this on today's Gamespot news
OverWatch 2 servers are now live but
players have been having a very hard
time accessing them since servers went
live on October 4th there have been
enormous cues to get in and oftentimes
players still cannot access the game
despite having zero players ahead of
them perhaps more notably blizzard boss
Mikey Barra announced that OverWatch 2
was suffering from a quote Mass DDOS
attack shortly after launch which he
says is causing quote a lot of drop
slash connection issues in a subsequent
late night update from game director
Aaron Keller it was revealed that a
second DDOS was underway but that
blizzard was quote steadily making
progress on server issues and stability
he added quote we're all hands on deck
and will continue to work throughout the
night thank you for your patience we'll
share more info as it becomes available
blizzard had previously acknowledged an
quote unexpected server error that some
players are receiving Additionally the
studio has confirmed issues with players
unlocks including skins not appearing as
well as watchpoint pack players not
having access to it there's no word on
when these issues will be resolved but
the blizzard CS Twitter account is
providing updates as they come in and
known issues list has been compiled on
the OverWatch forums at the time of
recording there doesn't seem to be any
concrete answers on how to circumvent
the loading screen or fix account
migration issues keep an eye on
gamespot.com where we'll be posting
updates to this story as they happen
2025 is not only the year you'll get to
play OverWatch 2 but also the release of
Call of Duty Advanced Warfare 2
according to a new leak reportedly
developed by Sledgehammer Games the
Activision Studio that led the charge on
2021's Call of Duty Vanguard reliable
Call of Duty Lika Ralph valve says that
the studio is hoping to abandon the
World War II setting of their recent
work and return to the Sci-Fi setting
that they left back in the mid-2010s by
contrast 2014's Advanced Warfare had a
more near future approach to things with
players donning mech-like exoskeletons
that gave them superhuman abilities like
double jumps it featured now disgraced
actor Kevin Spacey who was considered a
major coup for the series at the time
today it's probably best known as the
origin of the infamous press after pay
respects mean ralpha valve's report
suggests that Sledgehammer was
originally planning a follow-up to the
World War II themed Vanguard but that
entry failed to sell well enough to
justify that however another reliable
leaker Charlie Intel claims that they
have heard quote that there is no
Advanced Warfare 2 currently in
development at Sledgehammer Games
despite the rumors today considering
that Ralph valve and Charlie Intel are
both respected leakers it's currently
Schrodinger's Advanced Warfare 2. it
both does and doesn't exist but the
leaks don't stop there Electronic Arts
own website apparently hosted an image
for a game called Need for Speed Unbound
though this page no longer appears to be
online the name Unbound would be no
surprise as a previous report pointed to
this being the title and the game will
get an official unveiling from EA on
Thursday October 6th the game will
reportedly be focused on multiplayer and
include a feature called meetups where
players can sync up to compete in races
so Forza Horizon Need for Speed Unbound
will reportedly be developed by burnout
Creator Criterion games its first title
in the franchise since 2013's Rivals it
is apparently exclusive to PS5 and Xbox
series X and S for its console release
according to a report and it will also
be released on PC the rumored release
date is December 2nd 2022 and that is it
for today's Gamespot news have you been
having issues with OverWatch 2 are you
excited at the potential of a Call of
Duty Advanced Warfare 2 spoilers it's
one of the best in the franchise let us
know in the comments below and we'll see
you here tomorrow for more Gamespot news
[Music]